alle meinen aber relative kommen
wirklich und heute in einer
konzentration gebracht ich jetzt mit
vier paaren eine waffe mit noch
aufgeschüttet und sagen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
meine hände und herzen kommen zu einem
neuen video heute ist es wieder soweit
ich mich mit dem drachenboot
auseinandersetzen bürger verschlechtern
apa red über für manager ab sofort am
start weg und ein neuen videokonsolen
wirklich mal komplett ungeschnitten
wirklich mit 1 familie halten ist
wirklich andere youtuber übrigen freude
über das thema debattieren die youtuber
auf das gibt mir einen wird das versteck
bist ein richtiger gold ist ein
richtiger tobias auf trocken am steuer
erhebt der dortigen gemeinheiten können
solche gesten du kleiner
oh mein gott oh mein gott ist die gerade
wirklich umgefallen in meinem haus
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
tore für polen zurück mit einem neuen
letztendlich war in barcelona einsteiger
oder weniger schweren kann ich mich
normalerweise eher weniger
während kann ich mich normalerweise eher
weniger zu schaffen dann packt er
normalerweise eher weniger